[Music]  hi i'm interior designer and drew crew  member mikhail welch so here's the thing  i have designed for celebrities big  houses bathrooms i've even put  nightclubs in clients homes but what i  have come to learn is that it's all  about the smallest details i mean the  tiniest micro details that you could  ever think about so i've been tasked to  design a dowel house for drew barrymore  [Music]  and to make things even better i even  have a tiny little drew that's gonna  help things out i need matthew to  redesign a beautiful outfit that's gonna  get her ready before she walks in and  sees her new dial space now don't be  fooled this may be a miniature home but  i'm going to give you some large tips  and tricks that you can actually apply  at home  all right so let's show drew wait what  is this this is a surprise for you okay  let's try the clothes